who are an ordained minister I am indeed
son yes so there was a very busy
minister who encouraged you to pick up
the slack one of my summer jobs was on
Catalina Island off the coast of
California and befriended a guy named
Reverend Bob who was a great guy didn't
drink didn't do any drugs he just was
looking for a good time and he was a
Universal Life Church Reverend which was
actually started as a tax haven but they
also they they did weddings he came to
me one day and said Brian I need you to
perform a wedding because I booked two
weddings
same day same time different locations
and I what are you talking about I can't
do that he said no you can I'll just put
the certificate in the typewriter and
type in your name we send it off the
Secretary of State it gets you know
registered and you are legally a an
ordained minister and I said I can't do
this I really can this is the mid-70s I
can't do this but I really can't it pays
$200 I'll do it so I said here's a copy
of Cahill Gibran people like that and
just you know just talk to them and have
the bride sign here the groom sign here
you're done you know it's like okay so I
was I had hair down to here I was
sunburned I had shorts and flip-flops
and a Hawaiian shirt and I show up it
was at an airport and I'm looking around
and I thought oh my and this guy says
who are you but I would I'm the minister
let's where are we gonna do this he said
we're gonna go into an airplane a six
seater airplane and we're going once we
get over the Hollywood sign we want to
start the ceremony I go piece of cake no
problem inside of course I'm like we get
inside I'm next to the pilot then the
bride and groom and the witnesses in the
back and that's a twin-engine prop plane
so I have to scream
so I'm in the back going don't stand at
each other shadow
I'm just wheeling and dealing but it was
it was an acting exercise and they were
holding hands and looking to me the the
figure of authority how many years did
breaking back to one four in filming
terms and filming terms from pilot to
end it was just under seven years so I
you know I was playing a character for a
very long time who was just so
unbelievably tortured and lonely and sad
and it was nice to jump from that and
that it was incredibly fun to do but it
was nice to just jump into something
that was just a little bit lighter and
fun because people watch a big made one
of those series that watch in a very
modern way I mean people did watch it as
a window right equally loads of you
watching on Netflix boxset so you must
constantly meet people who are in a
different bit of your journey yeah I
meet people on a daily basis that are
just now starting the show I mean we had
a solid core audience from the the very
beginning but it was it was very small
but they were very passionate and that's
really why the show stayed on the air
and they're obsessed people are obsessed
by it they're obsessed by and you know
it's it's strange because there's such
incredible television coming out of the
UK but the UK was really one of the
place one of the only places on the
planet that Breaking Bad never really
found its home and I I didn't really
understand that but now finally people
are just you know now catching on but
also people gorging themselves on yeah
yeah it's all there auntie's just stop
used to stop yeah I just like three EPs
in season yeah I have already puddin and
I apologize but the only reason is what
it first started this we've got a friend
and he was like you've got to watch this
show it's a great Stella vision genre
scene just to piss him off I didn't
watch it
[Laughter]
and now I kind of feel like I'm left out
of the party that everyone's enjoying
you were the same weren't you Jimmy what
I would no no I was laughing that it
would you know Ann said we have a friend
and then didn't like just like they have
one friend we did the exact same thing
where I'm so sick of people talking
about the finale of Breaking Bad and I
had we'd never seen it my wife and I and
then we have what's it I just thought
I've got four episodes to go ruling
we've watched it all over Christmas
we're really excited Christmas the
finale really doesn't this point it ends
in such a beautiful great way
inhabit that character for that many
years you know he's a dark place to be
yeah was it hard for kind of Aaron Paul
to live like that yeah the first couple
seasons I kind of just lived and
breathed Jesse Pinkman kind of 24/7 and
I I learned from Brian Cranston who
played Walter White he said you know
it's okay to kind of leave that
character on set yeah I was doing a play
on Broadway and it's normal to see an
audience go side to side as they're
looking from one actor to it to another
very natural but what isn't natural is
to see this happen and that drew my
attention there was a kid in the front
row one one performance about seventeen
and he was doing this constantly I don't
the hell is that and I go over a little
closer as I'm talking and I take a look
and he's on his phone he's texting he's
like what's going on I'm in a play it's
okay just doing this and I started to
get angry and I and I I changed my
blocking when I had a big speech that
was full of bluster and I know that
there would be a certain amount of
expectorant that would target and I was
spewing you did something fabulous to
impress your wife I did I think you did
to impress your wife what did I do with
cherries Oh God you want to see it I've
got two cherries Oh God do you want to
do this with me I don't know I never get
hard to do is just tying a stem with
your tongue that sounds difficult yeah I
think you'll be impressed naming what
fits well
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah mine actually my wife was quite
excited about that
you you tell a story of young love I
think you were on your honeymoon in
Europe yes and you were on a was it you
were driving but on a train we went to
our travel agent to talk about this we
were mid-30s when we got married and we
knew that we wanted to start a family so
this was like it we wanted this
honeymoon to be really spectacular it
spent five weeks in Europe and it was
all so we started in Switzerland we're
gonna rent a car and then go to Italy
and the travel agent says oh by the way
instead of driving around the Alps up
and over you take a train there's a
flatbed car it takes three cars bumper
to bumper on a flatbed car and then they
put you know you and then you go through
the Alps by the way he says wink wink
there are three tunnels the first tunnel
is about five minutes the second tunnel
is about eight to ten minutes the third
tunnel is 50 minutes long if you're a
honeymooner and I said say so I told my
wife and she exhaled and said okay we're
on the train there's a van in front of
us with a bunch of Italian families in
front and behind us I mean as close as
you are I can see the people behind us -
couples - Italian couples and so we we
start going and we go into the end it's
a massive experience emotionally and
physically and the wind is whipping
through in it's pitch dark you cannot
see and it's it's fascinating and we
come out of the tunnel into the station
and I say to Robin that's one we start
again we go through the second
it's dark can't see anything we come out
of it that's to start the third tunnel
wait till it's absolutely pitch dark
here we go it's a small rental with the
stick shift and I am like trying to get
my trousers off she is trying to lower
her chair and we can't see that you
cannot see anything so it's all by feel
amazing one thing I learned for sure is
that never be completely nude when
transferring from one seat over the
stick shift
keep your trousers on and do it
afterward Hendy can't see funny I would
recommend it
[Applause]
so we are in flagrante as they say and I
don't know where to put my heads or
something and my wife is just come on
just you know now what's happening is
that my eyes are adjusting I can see her
profiles beautiful woman
love her with all my heart and I could
see her and Ed's or her pretty face and
it's great and I think the eyes are
getting no the eyes aren't getting used
to total pitch-black what happened is
that we were coming to a station imagine
I'm like this
I can see the the two couples the
Italian couples in in the car behind us
with their wine
and the women ghosts are bad stop it and
my wife says those three words to you
every husband wants to hear get off so I
get off the Italian family the the
grandmothers turning they're struggling
to put the trousers back and I never
found that we never found out if this
was a gag if he would if this travel
agent did this on purpose
knew all along it wasn't 50 minutes it
was more like 15
[Applause]
[Music]